here now with more two members of the
House Judiciary Committee who will
question Mueller next week congressman
Matt Gaetz
and Andy Biggs hi guys thank you for
joining me tonight I appreciate it
thanks Tammy good to be with you good to
be with you Matt what kind of circus are
you expecting from your colleagues next
week I trust that we expect that because
that's all we've had from the Democrats
up until now what do you think is going
to happen when this when this commences
the principal obligation of the
Democrats from their standpoint is to
use this committee hearing as a
launching off point to continue a witch
hunt that the American people would like
to do away with remember Tammy it's
almost 6 in 10 Americans who oppose the
opening of an impeachment inquiry and
what we have before us are the Democrats
presenting impeachment in drag they're
sort of dressing up a non impeachment
endeavor as if it were impeachment and
they're going to try to get a license to
continue their activity meanwhile we
want to support the work that Attorney
General Bill Barr is doing to figure out
why in the world we had 22 months of the
President of the United States being
accused of being a Russian agent with
zero evidence all the way through so we
want to know when Robert Muller found
out there wasn't collusion and we're
going to expose the bias as well well
this is one of the problems of course
when you don't control the House of
Representatives anymore right
we have a chance to change that but Andy
what's interesting is that the American
people want action they want answers we
know that they're not reacting well to
this it continues despite that don't we
want some real questions I mean this is
where the Republicans are going to have
to deliver as well I really use this as
an opportunity to get answers we as
opposed to some additional showboating
what do you think we can expect on that
end well I think we're working hard to
put together a list of questions that we
think are important things like the
origins of this investigation and the
special counsel what Muller knew when he
knew about President Trump not being a
target anymore of the investigation why
he waited till after the midterm
elections but but Tammy you're gonna see
a dud from the Democrats
tell you why because Muller has already
said he's only going to rely on what's
in his report and we already have a
tamping down of expectation
you can't yes but you can't trip but
look he had that weird press conference
taking this case in the first he took it
bigger and it was only political from
the start
any person agreeing to take this case
what is part of the problem the choices
he made with who he hired
I hope the Republicans are not
proceeding here Matt with the
presumption that he's going to play it
tight this is a man I think with an
agenda and it is going to be up to the
Republicans to to at least expose that
in the nature of how they handle a
questioning of mr. Mueller would you not
agree Matt I would we have to do more
than just question robert muller we have
to expose the bias investigation that
was run and we also have to expose the
substantial omissions in the Moller
report there were factual mistakes for
example people who had ties to the US
State Department and Western
intelligence were identified as only
having ties to Russian intelligence and
there were circumstances where Russians
tried to undermine our confidence in our
duly elected president by feeding lies
into the steel dossier paid for by
Democrats and I think that's the male
collusion we got asked about I hear you
I hear you but I'm gonna I'll ask Andy
this as well if you could ask one
question what would it be Matt can you
quickly give me one question I think
that we're gonna ask a question about
how he selected his team what were the
standards use what were the conflicts of
interest that he tried to tried to fit
through Annie what about you what would
you want to hear Tammy I want to know
when he knew Donald Trump wasn't the
target and why they waited so long to
reveal it to the American public to wait
till after the midterm elections was it
deliberately you know good those are
substantive questions and I appreciate
that because we're gonna have to hear a
bunch of those gentlemen congressman
thank you so much appreciate you joining
us tonight you